a standoff at the Polytechnic University
in Hong Kong is continuing at this hour
after students barricaded themselves
inside during anti-government protests
now some desperate students attempted to
flee but police appeared to trap them
inside the university by firing tear gas
and rubber bullets on those who
attempted to leave up to 800 protestors
gathered on the campus some of them
carrying homemade weapons like petrol
bombs and bows and arrows
please threaten to use live ammunition
if they failed to disarm themselves for
the very latest let's go live now to our
correspondent on the ground Charlotte
Shelton pill our Charlotte what's the
latest where you are Brian this is
without doubt one of the most highly
charged 24 hours of this five-month
protest movement so far now what I'm
standing is a few hundred metres away
from that University where that standoff
is still ongoing where I'm standing
there are still numerous riot police
walking around we've seen a number of
people being arrested or led away with
their hands tied behind their backs at
the University even more violent scenes
going on at the moment protestors have
been told to leave the campus area that
as they've attempted to run through past
police though they've been met by by
tear gas and arrest by those police
officers we're seeing images of
protesters being tackled to the ground
some of them dragged across the floor
during that arrest we're hearing from
protesters that they're simply too
afraid to leave the university at the
moment the charges that they face could
carry up to ten years in prison so there
is a real tension unfolding at the
University at the moment we're hearing
as well that they've been there for
hours now overnight many of them they
are running out of resources is going to
remain to see how Marines remain to be
seen how long they are able to stay
inside the University campus or whether
some are simply going to have to try and
surrender or make a break for it through
the police lines the Charlotte all
that debris were seeing behind you the
the bricks on the ground a testament to
what happened last night we have some
video of those dramatic and often
violent scenes let's take a look at that
right now police move in but protesters
set the entrance to Hong Kong
Polytechnic University ablaze forcing
them to retreat police made some arrests
and some students were injured despite
the dramatic and disturbing images the
night passed without serious bloodshed
something many had feared over the
weekend it remained a firey stalemate
hundreds of students inside the
University versus the police the
protestors using a host of weapons
including Molotov cocktails slingshots
and even bows and arrows to keep the
police at bay the students are
determined just as a horse is as Moore's
Wars I've already written my will but I
trust that my fellow students will keep
the protests going many of us here are
exhausted just like I am I was sprayed
by water cannon and it is still very
painful but I keep going Hong Kong
authorities of the university called for
an end to the confrontation and for
de-escalation
but the situation remains tense
the protests which have become a broadly
anti-government and anti police violence
movement have been raging for five
months now people in Hong Kong are split
on the matter but many continue to
support the predominantly student-led
protests it all started with protesters
wanting to safeguard Hong Kong's
autonomy but Beijing showing no sign of
changing its stance towards the
territory Charlotte what are these
latest developments mean in terms of the
big picture of the protests in Hong Kong
is this violence that we're seeing this
new escalation a new normal
well this week really has been extremely
chaotic there have been a bit of a lull
of the week before where it seemed like
these the number of violent clashes that
were taking place on the streets had
died down a little bit this week though
we have seen numerous people critically
injured in these clashes we've seen a
one man who lost his life after he was
hit by a brick that been other
fatalities that have been reported as
well just yesterday a police officer was
shot in the leg with an arrow this is
becoming increasingly dangerous on the
streets here and now what is lingering
over these protests has been overnight
and through today is this warning that
came from police late last night that
they were prepared to use live
ammunition if those protestors holed up
at the University at the moment didn't
put down their weapons that is something
that has alarmed a lot of people on the
streets here that this could become yet
more violent that we could see a more
bloodshed here on the streets of Hong
Kong a number of parents gathered
outside that university at the moment
playing with police to to act with
restraint very very upsetting scenes for
those parents that the Charlotte has
been something of a boost for the
protesters it comes in the form of a
court decision can you tell something
about that
yeah that was a bit of a surprise
decision by the high court here it ruled
that a band that was imposed under
emergency regulations by authorities
back in October on protesters wearing
face masks was unconstitutional and not
many people had been expecting that
ruling to come forward after who is the
challenge the legal challenge to the
facemask ban was brought by
pro-democracy lawmakers but it really is
something of a small victory for some of
the protesters here it must be said
though that despite the fact that this
ban has been in place it hasn't stopped
protesters wearing those those face
masks as they take part in these
protests and a hit routinely with tear
gas many of them as well trying to hide
their identities Charlotte thanks very
much for that from Hong Kong today